j'habite saint germain en laye en plein
centre dans un appartement que j'occupe
depuis 13 ans et dans lequel je me sens
très bien
je suis porteuse du spina bifida c'est
une atteinte à la moelle épinière et
quand je suis né il ya 51 ans il n'y
avait évidemment pas d'échographie ça
n'existait pas le jour où j'ai vraiment
compris que les enfants porteurs du même
handicap que le mien naissent plus parce
que parce qu'on les supprime avant qu'il
naisse et et que ça pour moi c'était
très juste insupportable de me dire que
j'étais
que j'étais une une miraculée quelque
part je crois que je suis vraiment très
bien placé pour dire va ok j'ai ce
handicap ok il n'est pas facile à vivre
ok c'est un combat mais n'empêche que la
vie est belle et la vie elle peut être
rendue très belle et puis finalement
dans les toutes les collègues que je
côtoie ou que j'ai côtoyés à la sécu par
exemple j'ai l'impression d'être
beaucoup plus heureuse de vivre que la
plupart de mes collègues mais parce que
mais parce que je suis passionné par
plein de choses et je suis passionné par
la vie je suis passionné par l'autre je
suis passionné par par part
par la relation à l'autre et est en fait
oui c'est ça je suis vraiment une femme
de relation est ce qui vous a apporté ce
cadeau
de se le dire en tant que
je pense que ma foi
m'a
le christ miam je sors quand je parle du
christ en fait je dis que c'est que
c'est mon frère en fait est que et du
coup je me dis c'est c'est quelqu'un qui
me soutient c'est quelqu'un qui m'aide
c'est quelqu'un qui me m'oriente c'est
quelqu'un qui me qui me fait penser à
l'autre et et du coup je pense que ce
désir d'aller à foix lumière par exemple
de faire partie d'alliance vita par
exemple eh bien
c'est effectivement ma foi qui qui qui
me riendeau vers ces mouvements là parce
que c'est vrai que si j'avais si j'avais
pas la foi
je sais pas si j'en sais rien j'ai couru
je sais pas comment toi répète il n'ya
pas eu un moment où où il ya eu un doute
eu un questionnement révolte par rapport
à la souffrance ou une très très belle
question
une question à laquelle j'aime beaucoup
répondre parce que effectivement c'est
ce que je dis
quand fu est lumière en fait j'y suis
depuis que j'ai dix 10 12 ans et c'est
vrai grâce à sa foi et lumière je n'ai
je crois j'ai jamais eu de crise de foi
a été fondé par marie hélène mathieu il
ya juste 40 ans vient de fêter les 40
ans de foi et lumière se sont en se les
communautés se réunissent une fois par
mois en général ce type dimanche autour
d'eux des personnes qui ont un handicap
mental autour des familles au sein
desquels il ya une personne qui a un
handicap mental et
donc handicap mental comme par exemple
les enfants trisomiques ou des enfants
polyhandicapés
c'est pour moi voilà une façon de donner
est une façon de me réaliser en fait
dans le sens où finalement j'ai pas pu
avoir un métier que j'aurais aimé faire
parce que ou physiquement je pouvais pas
ou scolairement ce n'était pas possible
du coup j'ai trouvé une
une autre façon de
de dire oui à la vie de dire que de dire
que finalement quelle que soit la
personne quel que soit son handicap
cette personne
peut être aimé et doit être aimé et doit
être accueilli comme elle et pour des
parents d'un enfant qui a un lourd
handicap de sentir qui peut être aimé
par d'autres que ses parents c'est
tellement important et pour moi ça je
l'ait compris très jeune et je me suis
dit hélas si je peux donner de la joie
des parents d'un enfant lourdement
handicapé si je peux leur dire mais
leurs enfants c'est pas rien il est est
bien pour moi c'est tout gagné un enfant
qui a un lourd handicap et il a paraît
il
à rien il a il a rien il est et du coup
de parce qu'il est par sa présence est
bien il peut donner il donne énormément
d'amour le fait d'aimer ses enfants
handicapés pour moi dès mes démêlés
famille et de faire comprendre aux
familles aux parents aux frères et
soeurs que leurs enfants que leurs
enfants que leurs frères et soeurs
à est un est un être humain au même
titre que les autres et bien pour moi
c'est
primordial ses premiers
ces premiers